- Women who achieved
something in their lives,
and got somewhere, have a responsibility
to educate the next generation.
(pounding electronic dance music)
I would love my music to
be something that would
entertain while giving a
moment of thought to people,
because that's something
that music did to me.
My name is Noga Erez; I'm a musician,
electronic singer-songwriter,
producer from Israel.
There is a very, very
strong feminine voice
in electronic music here.
A lot of women in Tel Aviv are badass.
Israel has been a huge
inspiration, and a topic
in my music because of what's
happening here politically.
I'm living within this
conflict constantly.
I wake up in the morning to this conflict,
and when something happens
I feel a part of it.
I talk about my government a lot.
I talk about politicians in general,
and the people who have
power to make things better,
and don't always do the
right thing about it.
Knowing that and feeling that
I'm in the middle of this
is also something that
creates an inner conflict.
I mean, am I involved enough?
Am I doing enough in
order to change things?
(pounding drum beat)
Music has always been a way for me to deal
with what's happening around me,
what's happening in the world,
and what's happening inside me,
and it's the best form of
communication that I know
from me to the outside world.